hi Erica it's perry Heyman kraft foods
i'm here at Davos and I loved your
question about what my vision is for the
rest of my life I spent about twenty
five years in business and what I really
want to do is as the president of the
kraft foods foundation is actually now
take that business experience apply a
social dynamic and actually do what we
would call Social Innovation so I am
looking for ways to do things like feed
the world but do it in a way that
actually makes sense for kraft foods and
believe me the answer won't just be
Oreos and chocolates but that's what my
vision is I think we need a lot more
business thinking in the social or the
nonprofit sector and I want to take the
power of the business of 50 billion
dollar business and apply that to one of
the most pressing needs in the world
today which is malnutrition and hunger